[Music]
congratulations erin order you got a
star on the hollywood walk of fame why
yes
this is crazy we have a picture of you
there's this uh there you are
wow that's yours team teen beat tiger
beat centerfold
i actually crush
i'm crying
i actually do that with some regularity
i just go to the star and i just lay
across it
have you ever been like once you have a
star
i would think you can't go visit it you
can't go check it out because people are
going to see you ah but conan you can
because i did it like a week after i got
it because you freak out because that's
not normal to get a star on the walker
frame it's a it's an amazing thing and
it's crazy and so i sort of secretly
decided to sort of skulk over there and
and check it out uh uh and i got there
and i'm in a i'm in the section with uh
gladys knight in the pips and the harlem
globetrotters and sammy davis jr and is
anybody noticing a pattern yes
i am seeing a pattern there yeah but at
any rate it's my favorite section
honestly and uh uh and i'm in front of
the hooters
are you really i am in front of the
hooters you're nearly you're you
seriously you are near the entrance to
it right in front of the hooters well
they asked me they said do you want uh
you could either be on vine street
because they do give you some amount of
choice in where your star is or they
said or you can be in front of the
hooters
is there even a question
i want people barking up their hot wings
on my
star thank you very much also it's an
excuse to go to hooters you know
no because you could be like what are
you doing here i'm visiting my star
then why are you in the restaurant
groping people oh well i don't know
about that
so you were you visited i visited my
stars trying to be surreptitious about
it only to be uh uh recognized by some
german tourists
who must think that this is what i do
that i just go by my star and just sort
of look at it um
that's sort of the impression we're all
getting now
you don't have to be a german tourist to
get that impression it's not too far
from the truth
sadly so if ever i need you and i have
to find you that's where i should go yes
to the hooters
actually i'll look in a lot of hooters
before i go to that one
i suspect you will am i wrong or do they
i've noticed this on on two and a half
men the the writers seem to go out of
their way to try and humiliate you is
this is this the case uh
yes um but also
more uh specifically to hurt me uh if
you've noticed i mean very often i'm
yeah i'll get hit in the face i'll get
attacked by a squirrel i'll get uh you
know
and this year it reached the height of
them actually setting my crotch on fire
was there even a reason in the plot why
your crotch would catch on fire
well i mean aside from the obvious
um
um after you go stand
[Applause]
no no no up not necessary that's not
necessary you were right you were doing
well and then you started touching it
and gesturing to it
and that's when you lost that's and
that's when you lost
i've got to cut it off there okay so to
speak
this show will never air